بس يا بنت في هذا الحدث العسكري الافقي
الرقمي لدينا 17 شركه صناعيا اما انه لنا
15 جهاز متطوره 13 منهم بدون طيار او
قبطان و10 بينهم لم يستخدموا سابقا وحصل
عليهم الاسطول الخامس لاول مره
[موسيقى]
تقوم بالتشويش عليها لذا سوف ناخذ هذا
الثوره للاقتراب من المصيرات قدر المستطاع
تعالوا معنا في هذه الجوله
[موسيقى]
نرى في هذه الرحله ثلاثه انواع من
المسيرات المسيره الاولى التي شاهدناها
يمكن ان تنزل تحت الماء نرى هذه المسيره
ايضا ولكنها تطوف على وجه الماء
ونتوجه الان لرؤيه الزوارق المسيره والتي
هي النوع الثالث من المسيارات المنتشره
هنا في مياه الخليج العربي
[موسيقى]
المسيره والتي تنتشر هنا في مياه الخليج
العربي
[موسيقى]
من الخليج العربي بديع يونس العربي